Some research has shown an interaction between heart disease and depression.
For example, depression can increase the risk of death from heart disease.
However, for many of the studies on the relationship between heart disease and
depression, it's difficult to determine which came first. For example, was the
person depressed first and then acquired heart disease, or is it the opposite.
In that the person had heart disease and then acquired depression. Here we can
refer back to what we learned in the research methods lesson, lesson two. These
studies on heart disease and depression were correlation studies, and as such,
we cannot make causal statements regarding whether heart disease causes
depression, or depression causes heart disease. However, we can say that the
two are related.